cordis demain satisfaction des
mouvements antiracistes après la
décision du ministre de l'éducation
nationale lionel jospin a annoncé que
des poursuites judiciaires allaient être
engagées contre le maire de montfermeil
pierre bernard et notre invité ce soir
dans un instant il va pouvoir
s'expliquer auparavant nous allons
regarder ensemble ce reportage tourné
cet après midi à montfermeil des enfants
d'une école parisienne ils se sont
rendus à la mairie où ils ont déposé des
dessins sur le thème de l'intégration
ils ont également chanté devant la
mairie pour tenter d'attendrir clame
bernard ses enfants qui chantent sur le
parvis de la mairie de montfermeil sont
venus en bus du 20e arrondissement de
paris dans leur école surnommé l'école
tout couleur des enfants de 30 pays
différents cohabitent sans problème pour
convaincre le maire les enfants ont
tenté cet après-midi d'attendrir son
coeur mais leurs instituteurs et sos
racisme veulent surtout lui faire
entendre raison
nous on est on est dans une école qu'une
école concédé qu la république c'est une
école de la tolérance et quand je suis
venu ici je me suis posé la question est
ce que le maire de montfermeil à l'école
de la région des cochons ou alors il a
raté quelques courses n'est grand temps
que monsieur bernard comprennent qu'ils
ne peut pas se placer au dessus de la
loi et qui ne peuvent pas à montfermeil
comme ailleurs décidé de tina les coins
sos racisme n'entend pas lâcher la
pression demain soir ils seront encore
là à l'heure du conseil municipal à
l'heure où les enfants seront au lit